one of the things that I really like
about your book is that you do have a
knack for finding the silver lining you
are somewhat your optimist him very very
optimist know now it's honest has worn
me down as you can see warned you down
no no I used to be nine feet tall when
we did that buddy cup yeah yeah exactly
I actually am seriously very optimistic
I'm optimistic partly because you mean
look at those those teenagers those hot
those high school kids in Parkland who
survived that massacre and look at their
articulation and their courage and their
ability to shame adults into acting like
adults I mean how can you be anything
the way they organize themselves the way
they spoke on camera yeah you know in
the middle of this media frenzy was it's
a beautiful thing to watch extraordinary
and there are other students around the
country who are taking up the cudgel and
I have taught for years half of my adult
life has been in classrooms in
universities and I have not come across
a generation of college students that
are as committed and dedicated and
involved and determined to improve this
country as the present generation of
college students I'll find something
else
[Applause]
you